phantom threat was directed by Paul
Thomas Anderson and stars Daniel
day-lewis and his supposedly final role
and I am clearly not in my normal set
I'm actually in LA right now with my
wife we for the very first time ever
received an invite to the Critics Choice
Awards which is happening tomorrow and
we're gonna get to go to that which is
kind of nuts I've been trying to become
a member of the broadcast Film Critics
Association for many years I've actually
been emailing them for two years and I
finally got a bit of a response and on
Thanksgiving Day last year actually I
found out that I was officially approved
which was really awesome Thanksgiving
present and that means I get to go the
Critics Choice Awards every year which
is really cool and yeah so that's why
I'm here in LA we're doing that and
since I was here I was like got to see
phantom thread because that hasn't
opened yet in Ohio and I really wanted
to see it and I got to see it in
70-millimeter which is even cooler and
this film is about a meticulous
dressmaker in 1950s London played by
Daniel day-lewis who meets a woman named
Alma who becomes at first his muse
eventually his lover and problems
eventually arrives because Daniel
day-lewis is character Reynolds is a
very serious artist I wouldn't really
say he views himself as a fashion
designer
he probably views himself more like an
artist he will sit with his notepad in
the mornings and try to create dress
ideas and if you chew your food
improperly or make too much noise or
speak to him when he doesn't want to be
spoken to or in any way disrupt his
routine his entire day is lost so this
creates a lot of difficulty for Alma
because she wants to be loved
in the same way that she's loving him
she feels like she would love to take
care of him and be there for him
whenever he would need her but he
doesn't need her that much or at least
he doesn't act like he does he's the
type of artist that needs human
interaction just like all artists do we
all need to connect and feel like we're
going back and forth with someone else
about ideas and that's one of the best
ways to create when you're in a mood
like
no matter what your art is if you're a
painter sculptor a filmmaker a writer
going back and forth other people about
your ideas or their ideas can be really
creatively inspiring but Reynolds
doesn't like to admit that he needs that
and so he likes to have people situated
in his life like they're a chess board
of sorts like you go there and that's
where you belong and this person here
belongs there and as long as you move
and the way that I know you always move
I'm going to be satisfied that's the way
he views life which creates a lot of
problems for them in their relationship
phantom thread is a movie that some will
consider boring because nothing really
happens there's very few large sequences
where you feel like something huge is
happening as usual Daniel day-lewis is
incredible in this movie saying that
he's great in a movie is kind of like
saying a studio ghibli film has amazing
animation no but he really does
disappear behind all of his characters
you recognize that it's him because he's
famous but there is no Daniel day-lewis
performance where you're like yeah
that's that's him because he just
disappears you can look at some of even
Robert De Niro's performances and be
like all right he's he's being DeNiro
you can't really do that with Daniel
day-lewis that's why he's so terrific
and one of the best actors ever but
since the film is slow moving I can
understand why anyone would think the
film is boring there are some really
great sequences one of my favorites when
a woman who is very wealthy who has put
a lot of money into the house that
day-lewis lives in she wants a dress
made for her she is not the type of
woman in his mind that he would prefer
to make a dress for she gets drunk a lot
she doesn't have a very good reputation
the more the best scenes the film is
when he has to sit at this party and
watch her get drunk and stumble around
in his dress and you can just tell that
he is seething with anger because this
art that he's created for her that she
is wearing she's tarnishing it and it's
one of the better sequences in the film
now towards the end of the movie a
character makes a choice to sort of
accept
something and it's going to work for
some and it's going to not work for some
this is the type of decision that a
great filmmaker will make great
filmmakers like Paul Thomas Anderson
they they take risks they have something
in the movie that is a gamble where it
could go both ways and I'm not entirely
sure if it worked for me there are
legitimate seeds planted leading up to
this choice and in retrospect you look
back and you think about his life his
past particularly with his mother who he
speaks of a lot and you started to think
maybe this makes a little bit of sense
but it didn't know how to present work
for me because I didn't really feel like
character wise it was justified it did
feel kind of out of left field besides
that I was mostly riveted by this movie
because of the incredible work from both
Daniel day-lewis and the actors who
portrays Alma who I believe her last
name was pronounced cripes Vickie cripes
Vicki creeps not entirely sure how to
pronounce her her last name but she was
marvelous as well and it's just filled
with amazing performances and it's a
very piercing look at the way an artist
with a very straightforward narrow
mentality has a difficult time accepting
others into his life and the toll that
it takes on those around him that do
care about him I'm gonna give phantom
thread a B+ guys thank you so much as
always for watching I really appreciate
it and thank you for continuing to
support my endeavors over the years
through film and the various things I've
tried to do it really honestly means a
lot to me the fact that I get to go to
the Critics Choice Awards tomorrow it's
kind of crazy to me because for a long
time I would just look on the computer
or on my phone at events like that and
think that's never gonna be something
I'm gonna be able to go to and I it's
just kind of nuts that I'm gonna be able
to go to this awesome ceremony that I've
heard about for years and I get to bring
my wife and we're invited and it just
feels awesome it's and I owe that to you
guys for for watching and supporting me
over all these years so thank you so
much guys if you liked this you can
click right here and get
starmon eyes
[Music]